werte damen und herren nach sie hier
sehr herzlich begrüßen in der
montecuccoli kaserne beim jägerbataillon
zum thema der aufbringung der miliz und
möchte mich bereits im vorhinein für
eine positive berichterstattung bei
ihnen sehr herzlich bedanken
mein name ist robert kulterer dienstgrad
hauptmann und ich bin der presseoffizier
vom militärkommando burgenland
ich möchte mich ganz besonders bedanken
beim hausherrn und dem bataillons
komponenten des jägerbataillons 19
oberst thomas air king der uns hier die
einladung ermöglicht hat um diese
pressekonferenz durchzuführen
zu den heute hier anwesenden personen in
der mitte oberst thomas erkinger der
bataillonskommandant des jägerbataillons
19 und der aufstellungs verantwortliche
für die aufbringung der miliz zur
sicherung unserer grenzen
hauptmann patrick bühler zur rechten von
ihm ist der miliz kompaniekommandant
dieser zweiten jäger kompanie des
jägerbataillons burgenland und wird mit
seinen kräften beginnend mit 18
mai hier auch an der grenze zu
unterstützern auf der linken seite des
bataillons komponenten herr wachtmeister
bernd los ist der kommando gruppen
kommandant und mit der führung der
eigentliche stellvertreter von hauptmann
patrick keller und wird ihn unterstützen
bei seinen tätigkeiten meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren herr oberst
ich würde sie bieten mit der
pressekonferenz zu beginnen dann vielen
dank meine damen und herren ich glaube
sie als hausherr der montecuccoli
kaserne güssing recht herzlich hier in
güssing begrüßen
danke dass sie der einladung so
zahlreich gefolgt sind und möchte nun
mit meinen ausführungen beginnen
das österreichische bundesheer ist die
krisenreaktionskräfte der republik
österreich
gerade in zeiten der pandemie ist das
bundesheer und somit auch das
jägerbataillon 19
bitburger land gefordert die
verschiedensten behörden und
organisationen in der bewältigung der
krise zu unterstützen
neben präsenten kräften und dem einsatz
von aufschub präsenzdienern konnte es
erstmals zu einer teil mobilmachung des
militärs
das jägerbataillon 19 hat den auftrag
eine kompanie des miliz jägerbataillons
burgenland für einen
sicherheitspolizeilichen
assistenzeinsatz am vierten mai diesen
jahres dieses jahres mobil zu machen und
die einsatzbereitschaft dieser kompanie
bis 18 herzustellen
die aufbietung oder ausbildung der miliz
kompanie erfolgt hier in der multikulti
kaserne in güssing aber gestatten sie
mir bevor ich auf das miliz bataillon
und die miliz kompanie fokussiere in
einem bad informationen über das
jägerbataillon 19 zu geben
das portal ist hier in güssing
beheimatet und dort in summe einen
personalstand von 300 berufs soldatinnen
und soldaten zu unseren aufgaben zählen
die grundwehrdiener ausbildung genauso
wie die gestellung von kräften für
einsätze im inland aber auch im ausland
der momentane status des bataillons ist
schnell erklärt und der spiegelt sehr
gut wider wie es uns momentan geht und
wo unsere kräfte sind vorweg das
bataillon ist gegliedert in ein
bataillonskommandeur und in vier
kompanien von diesen vier kompanien
befinden sich zwei kompanien im
sicherheitspolizeilichen
assistenzeinsatz migration und dies mit
aufschub präsenzdienern seit 27
dezember also beinahe seit vier monaten
im einsatz
ein kader zug also 40 berufssoldaten
befinden sich in wien für den einsatz
der botschafts bewachung sie sind diese
woche in einsatzvorbereitung und gehen
nächsten montag in den einsatz
botschafts bewachung eine kompanie ist
in vorbereitung auf die ausbildung von
grundwehrdienern die am 4
gleichzeitig mit den milizen garten hier
in güssing einrücken werden es werden
109 grundwehrdiener im mai hier
auszubilden sein und unsere profi
kompanie die cara präsent sein
befindet sich in heime situation nach
dem erfolgten auslandseinsatz kosovo
diese komponist vor zwei wochen zurück
gekommen und diese company wird am 27
aus dem nächsten montag ihren dienst
geschlossen antreten mit dem
hauptauftrag die miliz kompanie
aufzunehmen auszubilden und die
einsatzbereitschaft dieser kompanie
herzustellen und das ist eigentlich
schon der link zur miliz und ich möchte
sie jetzt kurz informieren über die
miliz in der montecuccoli montecuccoli
kaserne in güssing wir haben zwei
verschiedene miliz anteile der erste
miliz anteil ist der miliz anteil des
jägerbataillon 19
also mein präsent das bataillon hat eine
kompanie als anteil
das ist am main miliz anteil und ich bin
verantwortlich für ein gesamtes miliz
bataillon das jägerbataillon burgenland
und aus diese im jägerbataillon
burgenland wird jetzt eine kompanie
herausgenommen und mobil gemacht
deswegen sprechen wir auch von teilen
mobilmachung von kräften in summe sind
wir in güssing verantwortlich für 1000
milizsoldaten meine damen und herren sie
haben im rahmen der pressekonferenz der
frau bundesminister sicherlich
mitbekommen den auftrag nämlich in summe
13 milizkomponente im bundesgebiet mobil
zu machen und davon hat das
jägerbataillon 19 auf geraten die zweite
jeder kompanie des jägerbataillons
burgenland mobil zu machen
dies bedeutet und das ist mein auftrag
177 soldaten aufzustellen auszubilden
und für den einsatz bereitzustellen
die zeitlichen rahmenbedingungen sind
ein drücker tag wird dabei
einsatzfähigkeit 18 dabei wofür wird
diese miliz körper nie verwendet der
auftrag für diese kompanie steht fest
sie wird hier in güssing die bereits
eingesetzten grundwehrdiener kompanie
ablösen und wird sie einen
sicherheitspolizeilichen
assistenzeinsatz migration in güssing
beginnend mit mitte mai zweite hälfte
bis zum 27
juli also in der dauer von zweieinhalb
monaten durchzuführen haben
nun wir sind wir an diesen auftrag
herangegangen wir haben wie haben wir
diesen auftrag umgesetzt
es gibt jetzt zwei möglichkeiten mobil
zu machen jede kompanie im bundesheer
hat eine truppe nummer darf jetzt
beispielsweise anführen 08 15 als
truppen nummer für eine kompanie dann
sollen auch alle leben mit soldaten die
unter der truppe nummer 08 15
gespeichert sind werden einberufen mit
knopfdruck das ist die eine variante das
haben wir nicht getan
es sind in dieser zweiten jeder kompanie
des jägerbataillons burgenland 187
soldaten bevorratet oder beordert wie
wir sagen wir haben uns die mühe gemacht
und diese 187 soldaten vorweg
kontaktiert wir haben sie kontaktiert
mit der information dass auf kamerad du
bist vorgesehen für eine mobilmachung
und wie haben sie auch darüber in
kenntnis gesetzt dass wenn sie gründe
haben die sie daran hindern ihre pflicht
zu erfüllen
dann sollen sie uns das mitteilen als
gründe haben wir angeführt entweder man
arbeitet irgendwo im gesundheitswesen
oder in einem relevanten jetzt pandemie
relevanten bereich zweitens man kommt
aus einem quarantäne gebiet drittens man
ist selbst infiziert oder viertens man
hat soziale oder sonstige gründe
anzuführen wie zb vom arbeitgeber oder
auch soziale umstände oder auch
gesundheitliche umstände von diesen 187
soldaten haben 25 soldaten davon
gebrauch gemacht sie haben uns
informiert dass sie entweder als arzt
irgendwo arbeiten als krankenpfleger
oder auch gesundheitliche probleme haben
oder sonstige soziale gründe haben wir
haben diese geprüft und wir haben von
einer einberufung abstand genommen und
wir haben diese soldaten ersetzt durch
freiwillige soldaten des restlichen
jäger batterie und burgenland es gab
insgesamt aufgrund einer ersten umfrage
47 freiwillige soldaten die gesagt haben
wir würden hier gerne mitgehen
wir haben momentan die zeit entweder
keinen job oder wir sind verfügbar und
wir gehen hier gerne mit und wir haben
letztendlich für diesen auftrag 177
soldaten bereitzustellen
202 soldaten
berufen warum ein bisserl mehr das ist
die personalreserve weil wir damit
rechnen dass der eine oder andere
vielleicht sein e mail ich gelesen hat
oder es sonst die gründe gibt warum er
jetzt plötzlich nicht kommen kann also
die personalreserve ist mitgerechnet
wie organisieren wir nun diese
ausbildung wir haben einen formierung
starb gegründet der sich um die aufnahme
um die ausbildung um die entsendung und
auch um die idee mobilmachung nach
erfolgtem einsatz bemüht dieser
formierung starb umfasst natürlich
aktive soldaten des präsents stand des
mannes bataillons kommandos aber
hauptsächlich auch miliz offiziere des
jäger batterien und burgenland die
stehen hier im hintergrund
die haben sich bereit erklärt im rahmen
einer freiwilligen übung hierzu dienen
und bei der organisation zu unterstützen
wenn wir die miliz mobil machen
wir haben die gesamte teilmobilmachung
in vier phasen unterteilt erstens die
vorbereitung da sind wir jetzt gerade
mittendrin
es wurden die aufnahme und ausbildung
drittens der einsatz und viertens die
dem mobilmachung wie es jetzt der stand
heute am 21 april hier in güssing wir
haben die einberufungen allen soldaten
zugestellt das heißt jeder von diesen
202 soldaten ist jetzt informiert dass
wir ihn auffordern am vierten mal hier
ein zurück der formierung starb arbeitet
und funktioniert
die vorbereitungen für die aufnahme am
vierten mai und die ausbildung laufen
planmäßig
und vor allem die detailplanung vierter
mai sie können sich vorstellen 309
soldaten sollen hier einrücken erfordern
besondere planung und besondere sorgfalt
auch unter den jetzigen
sicherheitsbestimmungen und sicherheits
unter dem sicherheitsrahmen und daher
sind wir eigentlich von unseren
vorbereitungen sehr positiv gestimmt und
es läuft momentan alles nach plan
ich darf die gelegenheit nutzen mich bei
meinen soldaten zu bedanken und
bataillonskommandeur aber vor allem auch
bei der miliz kameraden die sich bereit
erklärt haben hier zu unterstützen im
bereich der formierung aber auch
natürlich bei der miliz garten und hier
sitzen ja zwei soldaten dieser company
die jetzt schon organisatorisch
mitwirken und mitarbeitern um diese
teilmobilmachung
zu gewährleisten und sicher zu stellen
vielen dank und ich darf jetzt über
leighton zu machen hat man hier auch mal
bitte danke warst ja von mir auch ein
herzliches grüß gott von meiner seite
hauptmann kilo patrick ich bin
kommandant wie gesagt der zweite jäger
kompanie jäger partner und burgenland
vielleicht ganz kurz zu einer
militärischen ausbildung eingerückt 2001
zur ersten leer kompanie in leibnitz
damals noch dann auf die jäger schule 11
2 auf der jäger schulen krank wird dann
über mehrere stationen auf freiwilligen
wunsch zum jäger partner und boomland
gewechselt und habe somit ihren gästen
eine militärische heimat gefunden
zivil beruflich bin bauingenieur und
gleichzeitig versicherungsagent das
heißt ich bin auf zwei füßen unterwegs
bin auf der einen seite angestellt beim
bauträger auf der anderen seite als
einzelunternehmer ein büro südlich von
graz privat privat eine eine
lebensgefährtin und für kinder zu hause
wie gesagt am südlichen kreis stadt und
beheimatet
jetzt ist unser auftrag ich bin teil
dieses formierung starb es unser auftrag
ist es jetzt eben diese diese kompanie
aufzustellen und die einsatzvorbereitung
zu planen
das ist grundsätzlich jetzt zu meiner
person ich gebe weiter und dann herrn
wachtmeister danke ich da brauche einen
schönen nachmittag wünschen mein name
ist bei uns jetzt in commander gruppen
kamen land in der zweiten hier kommt man
jedes jahr ins burgenland werde den
herrn hartmann bei seinen tätigkeiten
und aufgaben unterstützen und in seiner
abwesenheit vertreten zivil bin ich
verheiratet hat zwei söhne mit zwei und
vier jahren beruflich projektleiter in
einem oberösterreichischen
dienstleistungsunternehmen für
brandschutz und sicherheit koordiniere
unser büro in wien bei uns jetzt bin ich
im nordburgenland und meine schulische
laufbahn war ich hab die htl in wiener
neustadt für buchbar und tiefbau besucht
und zum schluss bleibt genug zu sagen
ich bin stolz dass ich teil dieser teil
mobilisierung bin und zum schutz der
bevölkerung einen teil mittragen darf
dankeschön so meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren wir jetzt einmal den teil der
drei herren und durch würde jetzt bieten
umfragen durch die presse ich danke für
mich
gilt es natürlich in jedem einzelnen
fall zu prüfen ist dieser grund relevant
oder nicht relevant bei uns in diesem
fall sobald der einberufungsbefehl
zugestellt sind in ist das ministerium
in wien zuständig für etwaige
befreiungen und da gilt es dann auch die
beweisführung zu führen dass die
notwendigen befunden oder bestätigungen
mit zu schicken
unsere aufgabe war in der ersten folge
mehr auszusortieren und gleichwohl deute
die wirklich einen grund haben gleich
nicht einzuberufen um also hier
bürokratieaufwand zu ersparen und auch
irgendwo eine planungsgrundlage zu haben
wie viel personal dafür brauchen wir wie
viele berufen wir über die enorm hinein
damit wir diese 177 man zusammenbringen
bzw das training also vom vierten bis
zum 18
tatsächlich zum einsatz kommt es gibt
hier einen einen ausbildungs katalog
welche ausbildung sie liege mit den
militär garten zu absolvieren haben das
entspricht auch den ausbildungs vorgaben
von grundwehrdienern und kadersoldaten
für einen sicherheitspolizeilichen
assistenzeinsatz migration wenn ihr der
teilbereiche herausgreifen darf das
beinhaltet die anwendung von
pfefferspray
das heißt zur selbstverteidigung das
beinhaltet auch kommunikationstraining
spricht das bos behörden funkgerät
handhaben und auch bedienen können
das beinhaltet aber auch das anhalten
und kontrollieren von personen und
ähnliche tätigkeiten es gibt dass ich
einen ausbildungs katalog der umfasst
120 ausbildungsstunden und diese 120
ausbildungsstunden werden wir mit den
militanten durchführen
wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe
darum dass die grundwehrdiener die
verlängert wurden jetzt abgelöst und
ersetzt werden das wird die aufgabe
vordergründig jetzt die aufgabe dieser
diese miliz mobil sein
die grundwehrdiener jetzt im einsatz
sind hätten eigentlich ende märz
abrüsten sollen und wurden mit aufschub
präsenzdienst um zwei monate verlängert
daher ist jetzt notwendig in der zweiten
maihälfte diese ablöse durchzuführen es
wurde vom bundesministerium für
landesverteidigung und der politischen
führung entschieden dass mit
milizsoldaten zu tun
die aufgabe der milizsoldaten genau
unserer milliarden wird es sein in den
drei bezirken jennersdorf güssing und
oberwart im rahmen eines
sicherheitspolizeilichen
assistenzeinsatz ist die behörden bei
der auftragserfüllung zu unterstützen
das beginnt also bei grenzkontrollen das
beginnt auch bei unterstützung von
gesundheitsbehörden bei der vermessung
beim grenzübertritt und es geht also
auch zur unterstützung der
bezirkspolizeikommandant und der der
bezirkshauptmannschaften bitte kompanie
einrücken oder wie geht es dann weiter
gibt es schon pläne zwar in einer ersten
planung vom ministerium angedacht auch
eine zweite miliz teilmobilmachung
schwelle zu machen diese ist momentan
nicht geplant also es werden dann wieder
präsenter kräfte
diese miliz company ablösen
bis heute gibt es noch weitere fragen
ansonsten würde ich bin mir bewusst dass
die pressekonferenz dann schließen sie
sagen vielen dank wir stehen jetzt
natürlich für fragen noch zur verfügung
wie sandro wenn es gewünscht ist kann
man auch einen blick in den formierung
staat machen wo man also dann wirklich
im personen bekommen kann
was machen die kameraden da der obersten
winkler steht ihr zur verfügung auch für
eine einweisung im gefechtsstand es
formierung stabes und wir stehen
natürlich auch für fragen und sonstige
bedürfnisse zur verfügung vielen dank
dass sie hier waren